OK.
Everything on Fox News is narrative journalism
and they've been caught badly and obviously
editing video to remove police with guns drawn
who were handcuffing the innocent Good Samaritan
black people at one of this week's protests
and understand that there's a contingent that
wants to put together a very specific narrative
about the protests.
And that narrative is the protesters are overwhelmingly
bad and violent.
They're insincere in their activism priorities.
The police are good and Trump is very good
and leading the country properly.
Now, of course, there's lots of different
details that make the reality a lot more complex.
Protesters are mostly good and police are
mostly good.
But a lot of this is about systems of power.
There's the issue of Trump's leadership.
Constitutional issues with the military.
There's endless issues here.
But what I want to focus in on in this segment
is Fox News distorting the truth in in just
a really specific way.
And as Rolling Stone reports, there's a local
FOX affiliate that ran a story about a family
flagging down law enforcement to protect the
business from looters.
When police show up, the officers handcuff
the people who were legally holding firearms
and trying to defend this business.
And Fox News when they rebroadcast this story.
They removed the entire part of the story
where police drew their guns and put the Good
Samaritan black gun owners in handcuffs.
So the local FOX affiliate, FOX Eleven, included
all of that because they were broadcasting
it live.
You actually see the police manhandling the
victims, pulling a woman out of a car who
had nothing to do with the entire thing.
They handcuffed the people who called the
cops.
Now, I can't play that for you because local
FOX stations are super aggressive in their
copyright claims and they'll penalize my channel
for doing it.
But here's the later clip from Fox News where
they remove that altogether.
The police showing up and harassing and handcuffing
the victims was casually, completely removed.
Take a look.
It happened yesterday in Van Nuys as well,
where owners of a liquor store were protecting
it with their long firearms.
When about a half a dozen looters showed up
and tried to hit a golden jewelry store next
door, there was a standoff.
And there the reporter became a witness.
Three vehicles drove up in front of the buy
gold.
And they told him, get away from that.
And they started arguing about it.
And after they started arguing about it.
That's when we started flagging you down.
So they were able to stop that from taking
place.
I think one or two of the looters were detained.
Now, there's two protests going on right now
in Hollywood.
What a completely sanitized and dishonest
version of what happened.
Liquor store defenders with legal guns who
happen to be black.
Defend the store until the police show up.
And the full story, of course, is that police
showed up, aimed the guns at the people defending
the store, as well as peaceful bystanders
and even handcuffed some of them.
This is Fox News going as far as Rolling Stone
says, out of its way to selectively edit the
scene and make the police appear to be nothing
but helpful and ignore the fact that the police
showed up, cuffed the black people with guns
first and ask questions later.
Now, in the video that went out live on FOX
11, which I encourage you to check out, you
can actually hear the reporter that was on
scene yelling at the police saying these are
the good guys.
No, these are not the looters.
These are the good guys.
You're cuffing the good guys.
And she's insisting and the police tell her,
you've got to calm down.
It's one of the most chaotic, insane videos
that I've seen.
You know, actually, it's so important, really,
that you see this.
Let's just play the FOX 11 video will probably
get flagged or whatever, but we can't really
tell the story.
Here is the insane video from FOX Eleven Live,
where you actually see all the craziness go
down and you hear the reporter yelling at
the cops.
These aren't the bad guys.
You're cuffing the good guys.
Take a look at this.
All right.
Now they're telling them not.
My gosh.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Joe.
All right.
Come on.
He's gone.
Yeah.
Okay, sir.
Sir, there's a store owner zealot protecting
the looters, sir.
The stores are looters now.
First, please.
You're losing your loot.
These are the people at the store.
Point all three of them.
We're putting those in handcuffs right now.
Where's the shooter?
You.
Where they're protecting this building.
Where the looters go.
Description.
Black, white, Asian Americans dare to show
you how easily and quickly things can go wrong
or can be misinterpreted.
Wow.
Christina, this is one of the wildest things
I've ever seen.
And then to see that you're taking the woman
from the car, she's not involved.
She just stopped to look.
They actually take a random woman out of her
car cuff and detain the good Samaritans.
It is completely bonkers.
So there's two parts here.
There's the story of police showing up.
And assuming that the good Samaritans with
the legal guns are actually the bad guys now
we can debate.
Is it about race?
Is it five percent about race?
Is it 50 percent of blacks?
That's one part of it.
Then you have the Fox News disinformation,
propaganda piece of it, which is that the
good Samaritans were detained on live TV.
And Fox News National has just removed that
completely from their telling of the story
and doesn't even mention it.
And this contributes to the overall narrative
that Fox News has been perpetuating.
The protesters are the bad guys and they must
be stopped.
The police are never the problem.
And sometimes the police are even actually
the victims, according to some of the presentations
that are made.
Incredible, incredible story.
Incredible situation.
Imagine being that exasperated Fox 11 reporter
who sees it all go down and then sees the
police cuffed, the good guys yelling.
These are these are these aren't the looters.
These are the calm down, ma'am.
Calm down.
Excuse us while we pull a random woman out
of her car for stopping to see what's going
on.
Sick.
And this is just one little story about so
many things.
How context matters.
Preconceived notions.
Selective news editing.
How these out of context, 40 second stories
on news channels often fail to really tell
us what's going on.
Many lessons to be learned here.
And it's also just another one of these unbelievable
videos that you have to see to believe that
this is what's going on.